When someone hurts you, a friend or former friend, a family member, a colleague, a romantic partner, it can feel justifiable or even satisfying to nurse a grudge. After all, what do you have to gain from forgiving someone who's bullied you, betrayed you, or let you down? But psychologists who study forgiveness say that forgiving, when done right, can be therapeutic for the person who's been hurt. Research has found that it can lead to better. mental, emotional, and even physical health. So when you want to forgive someone, where do you start? What steps do you take? How do you deal with the anger or grief that may be standing in the way of forgiveness? And can you forgive without forgetting? What is the difference between
当有人伤害你时，无论是朋友、前朋友、家人、同事还是恋爱伴侣，怀恨在心有时会让人觉得合情合理，甚至令人满足。毕竟，宽恕那些欺负你、背叛你或让你失望的人，你又能得到什么呢？但研究宽恕的心理学家表示，如果方法得当，宽恕对受伤害的人来说具有治疗作用。研究发现，它能带来更好的心理、情感甚至身体健康。那么，当你想要宽恕某人时，该从哪里开始？你应该采取哪些步骤？你该如何处理那些可能阻碍宽恕的愤怒或悲伤？你能在不遗忘的情况下宽恕吗？什么是
forgiveness and reconciliation? When someone has done something truly wrong, can you forgive them and seek justice at the same time? Can you forgive someone who hasn't hurt you directly? and is it possible to forgive someone who isn't sorry for what they've done? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Robert Enright, a professor in the Department of Educational Psychology at the University of Wisconsin-Madison.
宽恕与和解的区别？当某人确实做了错事时，你能在宽恕他们的同时寻求正义吗？你能宽恕一个没有直接伤害你的人吗？是否有可能宽恕一个对自己的所作所为毫无悔意的人？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校教育心理学系的罗伯特·恩赖特教授。
He is a pioneer in the scientific. study of forgiveness which he has been researching for nearly four decades. Dr. Enright has developed forgiveness-based interventions for children and adults who have suffered from bullying, abuse, and other injustices. He's also brought forgiveness education programs to conflict areas such as Northern Ireland. He is interested in how forgiveness interventions and therapy can help people improve their mental health and well-being. Dr. Enright is the author of more than 120, scientific articles and seven books and has been awarded many honors, including a 22 gold medal award for Impact in Psychology from the American Psychological Foundation.
他是科学研究宽恕领域的先驱，研究这一课题已近四十年。恩赖特博士开发了基于宽恕的干预措施，帮助那些遭受欺凌、虐待和其他不公正待遇的儿童和成人。他还将宽恕教育项目引入了北爱尔兰等冲突地区。他致力于研究宽恕干预和治疗如何帮助人们改善心理健康和福祉。恩赖特博士撰写了120多篇科学论文和七本书，并获得了许多荣誉，包括美国心理学基金会颁发的22枚心理学影响力金奖。
Dr. Enright, thank you for joining me today. It's an honor to be with you, Kim. Thanks for asking me. Let's start as we often do in this podcast with a definition. And I'm going to ask you something that might seem obvious. What does the term forgiveness mean? You say people often misunderstand the term, so how do you define it? I see it as a moral virtue where you are being good to those who are not good to you
恩赖特博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。金，能和你在一起是我的荣幸。谢谢你的邀请。让我们像往常一样，从定义开始。我要问你一个看似显而易见的问题。宽恕这个词是什么意思？你说人们经常误解这个词，那么你是如何定义它的呢？我认为它是一种道德美德，即你对那些对你不友善的人表现出善意，
without excusing, without forgetting lest it happen again, without necessarily reconciling, as you had said in your introduction, and without throwing justice under the bus. So I mentioned in the introduction that your research and that of some of your colleagues, you've found that forgiveness can benefit people's health, their mental health, and their well-being. Can you talk about that? What's the connection between forgiveness and well-being? The key is that when we've been treated unjustly by others, a lot of times unhealthy anger sneaks into our heart. And we're not even aware of that.
而不去开脱，不去遗忘（以免重蹈覆辙），也不一定非要和解（正如你在介绍中所说），更不会牺牲正义。我在介绍中提到，你和你的一些同事的研究发现，宽恕可以造福人们的健康、心理健康和福祉。你能谈谈这一点吗？宽恕与福祉之间有什么联系？关键在于，当我们受到他人的不公正对待时，很多时候不健康的愤怒会潜入我们的内心。而我们甚至没有意识到这一点。
And with that drip, drip, drip of the anger, onto the heart, onto the emotions, day after day, and even year after year, people start to become deeply angry or resentful, and then that can turn into anxiety and even depression and even low self-esteem not liking yourself. And as you reach out paradoxically with goodness toward those who are not good to you, and it's your choice, shouldn't be forced, that drip, drip of the anger starts slowing down, and in its place you start having, as I say, that goodness toward the other. And that actually counteracts the toxic anger, reducing and even eliminating the effects of the trauma in that the anxiety and depression literally can leave and you get your life back.
随着这种愤怒日复一日、年复一年地滴落在我们的心头和情绪上，人们开始变得极其愤怒或怨恨，这可能会演变成焦虑，甚至抑郁，以及自卑，即不喜欢自己。当你自相矛盾地向那些对你不友善的人伸出援手，表现出善意时——这应该是你的选择，不应被强迫——那种愤怒的滴落就开始减慢，取而代之的是，正如我所说，你开始对他人产生那种善意。这实际上抵消了有毒的愤怒，减少甚至消除了创伤的影响，即焦虑和抑郁确实可以离你而去，你也能找回自己的生活。
Now, if you want to forgive someone, how do you do it practically speaking? What are the steps that people should take? Well, very briefly, it's good first to understand the effects of the injustice against you, seeing that it's quite negative and that you've been living with negative effects like restlessness and too much anger and the like. And then you have to make a decision, How are you going to heal from that? And many people come to forgiveness when they've tried everything under the sun. And so they say, nothing's worked. I'll try forgiveness.
那么，如果你想宽恕某人，从实际操作层面该怎么做呢？人们应该采取哪些步骤？嗯，简而言之，首先要了解不公正对待对你造成的影响，认识到这是相当负面的，而且你一直生活在不安、过度的愤怒等负面影响中。然后你必须做出一个决定：你打算如何从中治愈？许多人在尝试了各种方法后才想到宽恕。所以他们说，什么都没用。我会尝试宽恕。
So you make a decision, a free will decision without coercion from others. And then when you, what I say, hit the forgiveness gym to do the forgiveness work to become forgivingly fit, you start thinking about the one who hurt you in new ways. You see that they're more than the injustice. against you. You see their personhood is what you do. And when you do that and then you're ready to give this moral virtue-like quality, which is goodness to the other, that's when the healing starts to begin in the heart of the forgiver, which leads to finding new meaning and purpose in your own life when you say, hey, I have a new way of dealing with trauma that I had never
所以你做出一个决定，一个不受他人强迫的自由意志决定。然后，当你进入我所说的“宽恕健身房”，进行宽恕练习以达到“宽恕健康”时，你开始以新的方式思考那个伤害你的人。你会发现他们不仅仅是那个对你造成不公正的人。你看到的是他们的人格。当你这样做，并且准备好给予这种类似道德美德的品质——即对他人的善意——时，宽恕者的内心就开始治愈，这会让你在自己的生活中找到新的意义和目的，当你对自己说：“嘿，我有一种处理创伤的新方法，这是我以前从未
thought of before. And it's there that you get a true psychological change that's transformative in a very positive way. Now, it sounds like all of this is coming from within the person who is doing the forgiving. Does the person who is being forgiven have to play any kind of role in this? I like your word, words have to. No, the other does not have to do anything, but it's helpful. if the other person is repentant, sorrowful, comes to you and genuinely apologizes without any nonsense, without using the apology as a way to gain power, that helps a lot. Yes. But you can make this free will decision to go ahead and to try and be good to the other, try and expand your story of who this person is beyond just the injustice against you. And it's your decision, your internal work.
想过的。”正是在那里，你获得了真正的心理改变，这是一种非常积极的转变。听起来这一切都来自宽恕者内心。被宽恕的人需要在这其中扮演任何角色吗？我喜欢你用的词“需要”。不，对方不需要做任何事，但如果对方有悔意、感到悲伤，并真诚地向你道歉，没有任何废话，也没有把道歉当作获取权力的手段，那会有很大帮助。是的。但你可以做出这个自由意志的决定，继续尝试对他人友善，尝试扩展你对这个人的故事，而不仅仅是关于他对你的不公正。这是你的决定，是你内在的工作。
And you know why that's so important? Because then the other doesn't have that kind of power over you anymore. See, you're free to do this whenever you wish. Think about it if your heart is damaged because of an injustice and you need to forgive and you won't or you can't until three little words are uttered by the one who didn't like you. I am sorry. that's giving way too much power to the other. But how do I know personally that I'm ready to forgive? I mean, I may feel like that's what I should do, but is it truly coming from within,
你知道为什么这很重要吗？因为这样对方就再也不能对你施加那种权力了。你看，你随时都可以自由地这样做。试想一下，如果你的心因为不公正而受损，你需要宽恕，但你不会，或者你不能，直到那个不喜欢你的人说出那三个小字：“对不起”。那是在给对方太多的权力。但我个人怎么知道我准备好宽恕了呢？我的意思是，我可能觉得这是我应该做的，但这真的是发自内心的吗？
we talk about heart here, is it coming from my heart? I think that's a great question. And people tend to know when they are ready for a new chapter in their life. They know when they're ready to go on a diet. They know when they're ready to have a new friend. They know when they're ready to go to the physical gym to get physically fit. They have a motivation. They have a direction in their life.
我们在这里谈论的是内心，它是发自我的内心吗？我认为这是一个很好的问题。人们往往知道自己何时准备好开启人生的新篇章。他们知道自己何时准备好节食。他们知道自己何时准备好结交新朋友。他们知道自己何时准备好去健身房进行身体锻炼。他们有动力。他们有生活的目标。
And so a lot of times, actually, people don't think they are ready because they think what forgiveness is, is caving into the other's nonsense. But when they finally hear that that's not what it is and you can stand firm that what happened was unfair and it's still unfair, but I'm going to try and give this unexpected, shockingly new idea in psychotherapy of deliberately being good to the other while watching my own back, then people know they're ready for this new chapter in their life, just like they might for a new diet. Does the forgiver have to engage in some way with the person they're forgiving? Does that matter?
所以很多时候，人们实际上并不认为自己准备好了，因为他们认为宽恕就是向对方的胡闹屈服。但当他们最终听到事实并非如此，并且你可以坚定地认为所发生的事情是不公平的，而且现在仍然是不公平的，但我会尝试给予这种心理治疗中意想不到的、令人震惊的新理念——在保护自己的同时，刻意地对他人友善——那么人们就知道他们准备好迎接人生的新篇章了，就像他们可能准备好开始新的饮食习惯一样。宽恕者是否必须以某种方式与被宽恕的人接触？这重要吗？
Well, it does matter, but it's not necessary. You see, if you can go to the other and say, I am hurt, this isn't right what you've been doing, may we talk about it, and the other's ready, wonderful. But the other might be deceased. And does that mean you cannot forgive someone who's deceased? No, you're trapped for the rest of your life. Think about that. But you can.
嗯，这确实重要，但不是必须的。你看，如果你能走到对方身边说：“我受伤了，你所做的事情是不对的，我们可以谈谈吗？”如果对方准备好了，那太好了。但对方可能已经去世了。这是否意味着你不能宽恕一个已经去世的人？不，否则你余生都会被困住。想想看。但你可以。
How can you be good to someone who's deceased? How about a kind word about that person, the other family, members, if it's a person in your family who's hurt you, or donating a little money to charity in that person's name. So you're honoring that person's name. You see, that stops the drip of the anger in the heart. So it's really a unilateral idea, just as any moral virtue is. When you're trying to be fair or just to others, you don't wait for others to make certain moves before you, for example, stop at a stoplight when you're driving a car, that's your choice. I'm glad it's your choice because with justice, there are definite repercussions for not doing that. But with forgiveness,
你怎么能对一个已经去世的人友善呢？比如对那个人说一句好话，或者对其他家庭成员（如果是你家里的某个人伤害了你）友善，或者以那个人的名义向慈善机构捐一点钱。这样你就是在尊重那个人的名字。你看，这会停止愤怒在心中的滴落。所以这确实是一个单方面的想法，就像任何道德美德一样。当你试图对他人公平或公正时，你不会等待别人先采取某些行动，例如当你开车时在红绿灯前停车，那是你的选择。我很高兴这是你的选择，因为对于正义而言，不这样做会有明确的后果。但对于宽恕，
it's also your individual choice, and you don't have to do it. That's what I like about it. How can you forgive someone who isn't sorry for what they've done or maybe even doesn't recognize what they did was hurtful? It makes it harder, and you can actually then forgive the person. for that offense. For the person to stubbornly insist that I have done nothing is another offense. And so you can go ahead if you're ready, if you know what forgiveness is truly, and you're not being coerced into it by that person who says, what's the matter with you and you want to do it, then you can go ahead on your own regardless of what that other person does. That's how freeing forgiveness can be.
这也是你个人的选择，你不需要这样做。这就是我喜欢它的地方。你怎么能宽恕一个对自己的所作所为毫无悔意，甚至可能根本不认为自己伤害了别人的人呢？这让事情变得更难，但你实际上仍然可以宽恕那个人。对于那个人固执地坚持说“我什么都没做”，这是另一种冒犯。所以，如果你准备好了，如果你真正了解什么是宽恕，并且没有被那个说“你怎么了”的人强迫，而你想这样做，那么无论对方做什么，你都可以自己继续前进。这就是宽恕所能带来的自由。
With the consequence, I am now freed from what this person has been doing to me. You mentioned a moment ago that forgiveness is a kind of moral virtue, but what if someone doesn't want to forgive the person who hurt them or isn't ready? Does that make that person less morally virtuous? That seems like you're putting the burden on the victim in a sense. You are if you misunderstand forgiveness. Because if we see forgiveness is absolutely necessary under all conditions or were morally weak, then yes, it would be putting the judgment actually on the victim.
其结果是，我现在从这个人对我所做的事情中解脱出来了。你刚才提到宽恕是一种道德美德，但如果有人不想宽恕伤害他们的人，或者还没准备好呢？这是否会让那个人在道德上显得不那么高尚？这看起来就像是在某种意义上把负担压在了受害者身上。如果你误解了宽恕，确实是这样。因为如果我们认为宽恕在任何条件下都是绝对必要的，否则就是道德软弱，那么是的，这实际上是在对受害者进行评判。
But philosophers use the term, here's a big one for us, supererogatory. Forgiveness is a supererogatory moral virtue. There's a lot of syllables in there. And what they mean by that is it's not one that must. be done under all circumstances. It's similar to altruism. Do you have to give money to every single person you meet on the street who has a cup and is homeless? No. Are you going to be condemned if you give to two people and not 10? No, you'll be praised if you do it twice. It's the same thing with forgiveness. Supererogatory means it's up to you in the context that's right for you when you, when you're
但哲学家们使用了一个术语——这对我们来说是一个大词——“超义务”。宽恕是一种超义务的道德美德。里面有很多音节。他们的意思是，它不是在任何情况下都必须做的事情。这类似于利他主义。你必须给街上遇到的每一个拿着杯子、无家可归的人钱吗？不。如果你给了两个人而不是十个人，你会受到谴责吗？不，如果你做了两次，你会受到赞扬。宽恕也是一样。超义务意味着这取决于你，在适合你的情况下，当你准备好时。
are ready. Is there a difference between forgiving someone very close, like a family member you might see all the time, and forgiving someone you can easily avoid, like an old work colleague? It actually depends on the severity of the injustice as to whether forgiveness in a psychotherapeutic sense is worthwhile. Oftentimes, I find when looking at the issue of helping people to forgive, the deepest, most profound hurts that can last a lifetime, oftentimes come from the family. Why? Because it's the family that's supposed to protect us. And when those in the family now betray us, the hurt can be much deeper than if a boss fires us. Yet at the same time, if that boss is very cruel to you, dumps you when you have a family to support,
宽恕一个非常亲近的人（比如你经常见到的家人）和宽恕一个你可以轻易避开的人（比如以前的同事）之间有区别吗？这实际上取决于不公正的严重程度，以决定心理治疗意义上的宽恕是否值得。通常，我发现在研究帮助人们宽恕的问题时，那些可能持续一生的最深、最沉重的伤害，往往来自家庭。为什么？因为家庭本应保护我们。当家庭成员背叛我们时，这种伤害可能比老板解雇我们更深。然而，如果那个老板对你非常残忍，在你需要养家糊口时把你踢开，
and others are mocking you, that might be much worse than anything you've ever faced in the family. In which case, that one really might need some help in an applied psychological sense. Both may need help, but in general, it's the family issues that cut us the most deeply. And that brings me to the question of whether there's anything that is unforgivable. I mean, we can think of a lot of transgressions, the Holocaust murder. I mean, there are many bad things that we do to each other. Is anything truly, truly unforgivable? For some people, there are lines drawn in the sand, and they won't go beyond that.
而其他人又在嘲笑你，那可能比你在家庭中面临的任何事情都要糟糕得多。在这种情况下，那个人在应用心理学意义上确实可能需要一些帮助。两者可能都需要帮助，但总的来说，家庭问题对我们的伤害最深。这就引出了一个问题：是否有任何事情是不可宽恕的？我的意思是，我们可以想到很多罪行，大屠杀、谋杀。我的意思是，我们彼此之间做了很多坏事。有什么是真正、真正不可宽恕的吗？对有些人来说，他们心中划定了界限，他们不会越过那个界限。
And we should respect that. That is their choice to forgive people for certain offenses and not others. But quite frankly, I have never seen any offense in the world that I probably couldn't point to at least one person who has forgiven. Let's take a look at the Holocaust, which you mentioned. Eva Moses' core, who passed away recently, broke my heart because she passed away, was with her twin sister Miriam in Auschwitz, the concentration camp in Poland. She made a decision to forgive, I'm going to put this in quotes, Dr. Mingala. He wasn't a doctor. He was a pretend doctor.
我们应该尊重这一点。这是他们选择宽恕某些冒犯而不宽恕其他冒犯的权利。但坦率地说，我从未见过世界上有任何冒犯是我可能找不到至少一个人去宽恕的。让我们看看你提到的那场大屠杀。最近去世的伊娃·摩西·科尔（Eva Moses Kor）让我心碎，因为她去世了。她和她的双胞胎妹妹米里亚姆在波兰的奥斯威辛集中营。她做出了一个决定，我要给这个词加上引号，去宽恕“门格勒医生”。他不是医生。他是一个冒牌医生。
But Miriam died because of those experiments. Eva Moses' core decided on her own to forgive to set her self. self-free. Others who were with her in concentration camp thought it was on quoting here, improper, unquote. And that's fine because it would be improper for them, but not for her. So we have to respect those who won't forgive and respect those who will because it's their free will decision to do so or not. Now, people often think of forgiveness in a religious context. Many religions teach the value of forgiveness. Do you think, and have you found in your research, that religious people find it easier to forgive, or is forgiveness just as possible and as
但米里亚姆因为那些实验而去世了。伊娃·摩西·科尔决定原谅，以让自己获得自由。那些在集中营里与她在一起的人认为这——引用一下——是不恰当的。这没关系，因为对他们来说这可能是不恰当的，但对她来说并非如此。所以我们必须尊重那些不愿原谅的人，也要尊重那些愿意原谅的人，因为这是他们行使自由意志的决定。现在，人们通常在宗教背景下思考宽恕。许多宗教教导宽恕的价值。你认为，或者你在研究中发现，宗教人士是否更容易宽恕，还是说宽恕在世俗背景下同样可能且
powerful in a secular context? Our research has looked at people from all walks of life, Muslim, Buddhist, Christian, Jewish, humanistic, atheistic. And we find that when people walk the pathway of forgiveness that's been worked out scientifically and are willing to put the time in to become forgivingly fit, I've never seen a person fail miserably, especially depending on their demographics. Okay? Let's think about it for a moment realistically. Isn't it true that an atheist wants to be fair or just in the world? Treating people with fairness, obeying the traffic rules, Absolutely, of course. And so there's nothing in the rulebook of forgiveness that says you have to be a certain kind of believer to engage in it, just like the whole world engages in justice regardless of culture because there are laws that might differ among different cultures, but they all have laws. And all people obey them or else. And that's just an example, the justice moral virtue, showing that we all, some level, definitely try to engage in virtuous behavior.
同样强大？我们的研究观察了各行各业的人，包括穆斯林、佛教徒、基督徒、犹太教徒、人文主义者和无神论者。我们发现，当人们走上科学制定的宽恕之路，并愿意投入时间去变得“宽恕健康”时，我从未见过有人彻底失败，这尤其取决于他们的人口统计学特征。好吧？让我们现实地思考一下。无神论者难道不想在这个世界上变得公平或公正吗？公平对待他人，遵守交通规则，当然是这样。所以宽恕的规则手册里并没有说你必须是某种特定的信徒才能参与其中，就像全世界的人无论文化如何都在追求正义一样，因为虽然不同文化之间的法律可能有所不同，但他们都有法律。而且所有人都要遵守，否则就会受到惩罚。这只是一个例子，正义作为一种道德美德，表明我们所有人都在某种程度上绝对试图从事有道德的行为。
Can it work the other way, though, where a religion says to you, you must forgive. This is what we teach. And you feel in your heart that you can't really forgive. Will that then sort of weigh you down in the sense that you want to forgive, but you can't get there? Yes, if you're misunderstanding your religion. Because quite frankly, I have never seen a religion that demands that you get. rid of your anger today. Okay. Usually there are windows. Usually there is compassion. Usually there's patience. Honestly, I have studied these. I'm an egg head professor, remember. I study everything
然而，如果宗教告诉你“你必须宽恕”，这是我们的教义，而你内心深处觉得你无法真正宽恕，这会反过来起作用吗？这是否会让你感到沉重，因为你想宽恕却做不到？是的，如果你误解了你的宗教。因为坦率地说，我从未见过哪种宗教要求你今天就必须消除愤怒。好吧。通常会有缓冲期。通常会有同情心。通常会有耐心。老实说，我研究过这些。记住，我是一个书呆子教授。我研究一切
that's in English, whether it's Jewish or Buddhist or Christian or the materialist philosophies of the day, that demands that you start on the road of forgiveness today or watch out. And now here's a message from our sponsor. Do you know how much your subscriptions really cost? Most Americans think they spend around $80 a month on subscriptions, but the actual total is closer to $200. Maybe you downloaded an app just to watch one show, or you got lured in by a free seven-day trial,
无论是犹太教、佛教、基督教还是当代的唯物主义哲学，它们都要求你从今天开始踏上宽恕之路，否则后果自负。现在，这是一条来自我们赞助商的消息。你知道你的订阅费用到底是多少吗？大多数美国人认为他们每月在订阅上花费约80美元，但实际总额接近200美元。也许你下载了一个应用程序只是为了看一个节目，或者被七天的免费试用所吸引，
and then you forgot all about it. I know I've done that. If you have forgotten or have unwanted subscriptions, or if you don't know exactly how much you're spending every month, then you need Rocket Money. Rocket Money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions, monitors your spending,
然后你就把它忘得一干二净了。我知道我做过这种事。如果你忘记了或有不需要的订阅，或者如果你不知道自己每月到底花了多少钱，那么你需要Rocket Money。Rocket Money是一款个人理财应用程序，它可以查找并取消你不需要的订阅，监控你的支出，
and helps you lower your bills all in one place. Rocket Money will quickly and easily find your subscriptions for you and for any you don't want to pay for any more, just hit cancel and Rocket Money will cancel them for you. It's that easy. Rocket Money also helps you manage all your finance. in one place and automatically categorize your expenses so you can easily track your budget in real time and also get alerted if anything looks off. More than 3 million people have used
并帮助你在一个地方降低账单。Rocket Money将快速轻松地为你找到订阅项目，对于任何你不想再付费的项目，只需点击取消，Rocket Money就会为你取消。就是这么简单。Rocket Money还可以帮助你管理所有的财务，并将你的支出自动分类，这样你就可以轻松地实时跟踪你的预算，如果有什么看起来不对劲，还会收到提醒。超过300万人使用了
Rocket Money saving the average person up to $720 a year. So stop throwing your money away. Cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage your expenses the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash APA. That's rocketmoney.com slash APA. Rocketmoney.com slash APA. Now, you and your colleagues have developed forgiveness education programs for schools. What's the goal of those programs and how do they work? The goal for children is to prepare them for adulthood. Isn't that what good education is always about? Why do we teach children to read? So when they're in a grocery store, as an adult, they can read the mayonnaise jar to see how many calories there are. How about teaching them mathematics so they can balance a checkbook? Why don't we prepare children for the storms of injustice
Rocket Money，平均每年为每个人节省高达720美元。所以别再浪费钱了。通过访问rocketmoney.com/APA，以简单的方式取消不需要的订阅并管理你的支出。也就是rocketmoney.com/APA。Rocketmoney.com/APA。现在，你和你的同事已经为学校开发了宽恕教育项目。这些项目的目标是什么，它们是如何运作的？对孩子的目标是为他们的成年生活做准备。这不正是良好教育的意义所在吗？我们为什么要教孩子阅读？这样当他们成年后在杂货店时，他们可以阅读蛋黄酱罐子上的标签，看看有多少卡路里。教他们数学以便他们能平衡支票簿怎么样？我们为什么不为孩子们准备好成年后将会遇到的
in adulthood that will visit them? I've never been able to figure that out. And so what we're doing is we're preparing children for the storms of injustice that will hit them in adulthood, not by getting them into forgiveness therapy as children, but simply introducing. them to what forgiveness is through stories. There are a lot of picture books out there for four-year-olds, five-year-old, six-year-olds, that show conflict and show how story characters work through that conflict. Sometimes with more conflict and other times
不公正的风暴呢？我一直没能想通这一点。所以我们正在做的是，为孩子们准备好成年后将会遇到的不公正风暴，不是让他们在童年时期就接受宽恕治疗，而只是通过故事向他们介绍什么是宽恕。市面上有很多为四岁、五岁、六岁孩子准备的绘本，展示了冲突以及故事角色如何解决这些冲突。有时伴随着更多的冲突，而另一些时候
with actually deliberately trying to get along by seeing the humanity and the other. Because as Horton said in Horton hears a who, a person is what? A person is a person no matter how small. Oh, even if they hurt you? Right now we get the sense of children seeing what forgiveness is so that on their own, when they mature more philosophically and rationally, they can make their own decisions whether to do this or not. Because I worked with a 35-year-old woman recently whose husband just abandoned her. And she has two children and has to get a new job and she said to me, I want to forgive, but I don't know how. What if she knew how to forgive
则是通过看到对方的人性，真正刻意地尝试和睦相处。因为正如《霍顿听到了呼呼的声音》中的霍顿所说，一个人是什么？无论多么渺小，一个人就是一个人。哦，即使他们伤害了你？现在我们让孩子们理解什么是宽恕，这样当他们更成熟、更理性时，他们可以自己决定是否这样做。因为我最近与一位35岁的女性合作，她的丈夫刚刚抛弃了她。她有两个孩子，必须找一份新工作，她对我说，我想宽恕，但我不知道怎么做。如果她知道如何通过
through forgiveness education? Her life at 35 would be much better. Now, are there any kind of demographic differences in who is able to forgive? Are women more able to forgive because of the socialization that we go through? Or would you find, I mean, there are stereotypes and I happen to be part Irish and part Italian, and we all supposedly hold grudges. Do you find things like that in your research? I have not found gender differences in how people successfully go through our psychotherapeutic process when they've been traumatized. There is some research authors that suggests, and it's only some because not all of it says this, women statistically sometimes are more open to forgiving. I have found when I give talks on forgiveness that if you did a head count,
宽恕教育来宽恕呢？她35岁时的生活会好得多。那么，在谁能够宽恕方面是否存在人口统计学差异？女性是否因为我们所经历的社会化过程而更能够宽恕？或者你会发现，我的意思是，存在刻板印象，我恰好有一半爱尔兰血统和一半意大利血统，我们都被认为会记仇。你在研究中发现过类似的情况吗？在人们遭受创伤后，我没有发现性别在成功完成我们的心理治疗过程方面存在差异。有一些研究作者认为，而且只是部分研究，因为并非所有研究都这么说，女性在统计学上有时更愿意宽恕。我发现当我进行关于宽恕的演讲时，如果清点一下人数，
there are more women in the audience. And I have more graduate students studying forgiveness with me who are women. So I think it's an interesting point, Kim. Maybe there is something there. But at the end of the day, when men and women are definitely motivated to forgive, both can forgive with equal accuracy. Let's talk for a minute about the role of forgiveness in social and geopolitical issues where you've done some work. In my intro, I mentioned Northern Ireland. Can you tell us about the work you've done there and in other countries?
观众中女性更多。而且我指导的攻读宽恕研究的研究生中，女性也更多。所以我认为这是一个有趣的观点，金。也许确实有某种联系。但归根结底，当男性和女性都确实有动力去宽恕时，两者都能以同样的准确度进行宽恕。让我们花点时间谈谈宽恕在社会和地缘政治问题中的作用，你在这方面做过一些工作。在我的介绍中，我提到了北爱尔兰。你能告诉我们你在那里和其他国家所做的工作吗？
Okay. Usually we are asked in. See, I don't push myself into anywhere. And so in Northern Ireland, Anne Galaher, as with Eva Moses' core, she died and broke my heart. She had a peace movement in Northern Ireland. She had family members who were part of the difficult. there, what they called the troubles. And she said, come to Northern Ireland and help us understand forgiveness alongside the quest for justice. And so I came, and she introduced me to
好的。通常我们是被邀请去的。你看，我不会强行介入任何地方。所以在北爱尔兰，安·加拉赫，就像伊娃·摩西·科尔一样，她去世了，这让我心碎。她在北爱尔兰有一个和平运动。她的家庭成员是那里所谓的“动乱”的一部分。她说，来北爱尔兰，帮助我们在追求正义的同时理解宽恕。所以我去了，她把我介绍给了
school principals there. And at first, the school principals, rightly so, were skeptical of the idea of forgiveness because they thought we were moving directly into political realm, the Irish Catholics versus British Protestants. No, no, no. We were. We're interested in children and what they do when another child pushes the one down and skins the person's knee or steals your orange at the lunch counter. And so we're more interested in the person-to-person issues within their own community. You see, so that eventually as they develop their forgiveness muscle, as we say, and become more forgivingly fit, they might, if they so choose, start applying. that in the political realm. And I had the same thing with the school superintendent in the West Bank, where he said, the anger we have within our community here in the Middle East is destroying
那里的中学校长。起初，中学校长们理所当然地对宽恕的想法持怀疑态度，因为他们认为我们正在直接进入政治领域，即爱尔兰天主教徒与英国新教徒的对立。不，不，不。我们感兴趣的是孩子，以及当另一个孩子把一个孩子推倒并擦伤了膝盖，或者在午餐柜台偷了你的橙子时，他们会怎么做。所以我们更关心他们自己社区内的人与人之间的问题。你看，这样当他们发展出我们所说的“宽恕肌肉”，并变得更加“宽恕健康”时，如果他们愿意，他们可能会开始在政治领域应用这一点。我在西岸的学校主管那里也遇到了同样的情况，他说，我们在中东社区内部的愤怒正在摧毁
within our own community, individuals, families, and the local community. Could you help us reduce our anger level by practicing forgiveness locally? And we have done that. And so the key, is to not get involved in the political realm first, to get involved with the individual human heart, the family, and the local community, and let's see where that develops. That is actually one of my big goals, my big dreams with this work I've been doing for 38 years, is to change the peace movement where it brings forgiveness into the conversation, not to usurp anything that's been done. But dialogue by itself can appear very neat and tidy and respectful, but away from the peace table, if the hearts aren't right, hatred can continue. I want to see
我们自己的社区，包括个人、家庭和当地社区。你能通过在当地实践宽恕来帮助我们降低愤怒水平吗？我们已经做到了。所以关键是，不要先介入政治领域，要介入个人的人心、家庭和当地社区，看看事态如何发展。这实际上是我从事这项工作38年来的大目标、大梦想之一，那就是改变和平运动，将宽恕引入对话，而不是篡夺已经完成的任何事情。但对话本身可能看起来非常整洁、有序且相互尊重，但如果离开了和平谈判桌，如果人心不正，仇恨可能会持续。我想看到
forgiveness as part of dialogue and as part of solutions alongside justice. It sounds as if you're working a lot with the younger generations. And I'm wondering if in some instances we're just going to have to wait for the next group of children effectively to become adults in order to work through some of these issues. I mean, I think of the Middle East in particular, even what we're seeing between Russia and Ukraine right now. That's right. I think that's extremely insightful, actually, and that's correct. I think we need to bring two generations of children and adolescence through forgiveness, so they mature in that, they become, as I had said before, forgivingly fit, so that they can apply that alongside other issues that have been tried.
宽恕成为对话的一部分，成为与正义并行的解决方案的一部分。听起来你和年轻一代合作得很多。我想知道在某些情况下，我们是否只能等待下一代孩子真正成为成年人，才能解决其中一些问题。我的意思是，我特别想到了中东，甚至是我们现在在俄罗斯和乌克兰之间看到的情况。没错。我认为这非常有洞察力，实际上，这是正确的。我认为我们需要让两代儿童和青少年通过宽恕教育成长起来，这样他们在其中成熟，正如我之前所说，变得“宽恕健康”，以便他们能够将其与已经尝试过的其他问题结合起来应用。
Okay, how long is it going to take if we bring two generations through? What, about 20 to 40 years? How long has the difficulties been going on in Northern Ireland? Hundreds of years. How long in the Middle East? thousands. And so how is 40 years an exhausted amount of time where we should forget it? No, that's a blink of an eye. I think we should try this by having the humility to say those who come after us might find a better way. So you mentioned you've been at this for 38 years.
好的，如果我们让两代人通过这个过程，需要多长时间？大约20到40年？北爱尔兰的困难持续了多久？几百年。中东呢？几千年。那么40年怎么会是一个让人精疲力竭的时间，以至于我们应该放弃呢？不，那只是眨眼之间。我认为我们应该尝试这样做，保持谦逊，说那些在我们之后来的人可能会找到更好的方法。所以你提到你已经从事这项工作38年了。
What keeps you going? What are you working on now? What are the questions that you still need to answer. Okay. What keeps me going is the passion for what we find, it has actually surprised me the strength of the findings when people are gravely hurting psychologically and are healed from, let's say, major depressive disorder. And that gives me a hope, and the hope keeps me going, that we can indeed create a better world one heart at a time. And so I would say on the table, as my wish list, more insight that forgiveness education is worthwhile for children and adolescents, and here's a big one, community forgiveness. And we're actually starting to work on that in different war-torn communities, especially in Africa. We've been approached by four different
是什么让你坚持下去？你现在在做什么？你还有哪些问题需要回答？好的。让我坚持下去的是对我们所发现的事物的热情，当人们在心理上受到严重伤害并从（比如）重度抑郁症中治愈时，研究结果的强度实际上让我感到惊讶。这给了我希望，而希望让我坚持下去，即我们确实可以一次一颗心地创造一个更美好的世界。所以我想说，在我的愿望清单上，更多关于宽恕教育对儿童和青少年有价值的见解，还有一个重要的，就是社区宽恕。我们实际上已经开始在不同的饱受战争蹂躏的社区，特别是在非洲，着手研究这个问题。我们已经接触了四个不同的
communities in different geographic areas of Africa coming to us, saying, can you help us? We have had civil wars. I just had a meeting this past week with someone from an African community who told me one million people, Kim, one million people have died in this century from the civil wars. And he said, we need to bring forgiveness into communities into individual hearts, families, and communities, and then community to community. But see, both communities have to be astute enough and motivated enough to become well-versed in forgiveness, and then what will happen. I want to find out. Well, Dr. Enright, I want to thank you for joining me today.
非洲不同地理区域的社区，他们来找我们说，你能帮帮我们吗？我们经历了内战。我上周刚与一位来自非洲社区的人开会，他告诉我，金，在这个世纪里，有一百万人死于内战。他说，我们需要将宽恕带入社区，带入个人的内心、家庭和社区，然后是社区与社区之间。但你看，两个社区都必须足够敏锐、足够有动力去精通宽恕，然后会发生什么。我想找出答案。好的，恩赖特博士，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。
This is an extremely important work that you're doing. Thank you so much. Thank you so much for having me, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us. a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking
你所做的是一项极其重要的工作。非常感谢。非常感谢你邀请我，金。你可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Stitcher、YouTube或你获取最喜爱播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们：speaking
of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
of psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔达扬。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。